[Música]
[Aplausos]
un gran poder conlleva una gran
responsabilidad porque estoy diciendo
esto porque para mí poder hablar frente
a todos ustedes es mi gran poder y
decirles algo que los motive es mi gran
responsabilidad
a todo esto ustedes ahorita me podrán
ver muy bien muy sano muy guapo
[Aplausos]
pero esto no siempre fue así a los 3
años a mí me detectaron leucemia aguda
linfoblástica lo cual es la gripe del
cáncer porque es la más frecuente en
niños
cuando yo empecé mi tratamiento a mí me
hubiera gustado que alguien de mis
compañeros me hubiera explicado pero me
hubiera explicado bien cómo iban a ser
los tratamientos los procedimientos todo
pero desgraciadamente esto no fue así
ellos no querían hablar de eso a ellos
no les gustaba se encerraban en su
burbuja
así que cuando les quería preguntar
ellos no te querían responder ellos como
si nada y los doctores no eran los
mejores para explicar por qué me decían
te vamos a poner una vincristina por
ejemplo yo les hacía caso porque era
para mi bien pero yo no sabía cómo me
iba a sentir después que iba a pasar
y eso también me culpa por no querer
preguntar yo también me encerraba en
esta burbuja que les acabo de mostrar no
quise salir de ella en mucho tiempo
poco a poco tuve que ir saliendo pero
antes de eso a mí me gustaba mucho
distraerme con diferentes cosas comer
películas ese tipo de cosas de ahí yo
agarré mi gusto por el cine la tele y
todo ese tipo de cosas al no poder hacer
nada lo único que tenía a mi disposición
era una peli por ejemplo
así fue pasó el tiempo y yo vi que tenía
que salir de esta burbuja ponchar la y
dejarla ir no me iba no me iba a quedar
de brazos cruzados viendo como otros
niños no sabían qué iba a pasar cuando
otros niños se sentían muy mal así que
yo junto con mi abuela tomamos la
decisión de ayudar a otros aquí está
toda mi familia siempre me estuvo
apoyando nunca me dejaron
yo le agradezco mucho en específico a mi
mamá por siempre trabajar para mí para
ello tener una buena educación un buen
hospital y tener una buena salud a mi
abuela por siempre acompañarme al
hospital y nunca dejarme solo podemos
estar ahí desde las 8 de la mañana hasta
las 3 de la mañana y ella puede ser muy
paciente
y también le agradezco a mi doctora he
estado siempre conmigo siempre me ha
apoyado siempre estado en cada paso
conmigo nunca me antes nunca me ha
dejado ninguno de ninguna de ellas
y tampoco ningún ninguna persona de mi
familia me ha dejado siempre me han
estado apoyando en cada paso que doy
a mí me gustaba mucho ayudar en el
hospital porque yo les podía explicar a
los niños cómo iban a ser cómo se iban a
sentir por ejemplo con lavín christina
que les acabo de decir les podía decir
que se podían sentir mareados con dolor
de cabeza podrían vomitar pero les
explicaba que era para su bien algunos
podía algunos había muchas veces que se
querían rendir que querían tirar la
toalla
pero yo decía que no la tiren que sigan
adelante y puedan seguir luchando
pasó el tiempo yo me reí yo me curé pero
tú recae no solo tan malo conseguí un
muy buen amigo al recaer él es mi mejor
amigo en el hospital luís necesito así
yo le decía ahí están viendo que
nosotros estamos jugando con legos
porque ahí no había nada que hacer era
algo aburridísimo estar acostado todo el
tiempo en una camilla sin poder hacer
nada solo poder ver aunque sea una peli
cuando estaban cuando te estabas
debilitando las piernas y no te estaba
sintiendo bien
lo mejor que podíamos hacer era dejar
volar nuestra imaginación crear
divertirnos un poco con los legos así
que era algo entretenido algo que nos
distraía del hospital
también hacíamos cosas que no estaban
bien que algunos van a decir no pueden
hacer eso es un hospital lo hacíamos
para divertirnos
lo que hacíamos era meter espadas de
juguete corríamos un gran riesgo de
quedarnos en las agujas y jalar nos las
y que nos tuvieran que volver a aplicar
pero sí hubo veces en las que pasó pero
de todas formas nosotros nos seguíamos
haciendo para divertirnos para no dejar
de jugar obviamente yo siempre ganaba
con esta espada
era muy divertido porque algo y también
llevábamos a veces comida no era lo
mejor porque nos podíamos enfermar del
estómago
de todas formas lo corríamos para comer
algo no era siempre solo era cuando nos
cansábamos de la comida del hospital
porque ni era bueno y nos daban
porciones muy chicas
había doctores que cuando llevábamos la
comida lo regañaban y había también
doctores que cuando veían las espadas
nos regañaba otros nos pedían de la
comida y se ponían a jugar con nosotros
como este doctor el es el doctor carlos
es ahora es un grande un homólogo que
cumplió su sueño de hacer su consultorio
agradable para los niños como por
ejemplo darles camisetas hacer juegos
entretenidos para que no sea aburrida su
estancia para que se puedan entretener
para que no tengan que andar todo el
tiempo en una camilla súper incómoda a
veces que que te va a debilitar las
piernas
cuando no nos veía jugar con las espadas
y él siempre nos decía oigan presten de
una me toca y así era y le tocaba y
jugábamos nos divertíamos mucho
a mi amigo le tocó eso un día pero no
fue por algo malo fue porque ella había
acabado parte de su tratamiento yo me
puse a llorar al principio pero tuve que
comprender y ponchar de nuevo la burbuja
que era algo bueno no algo malo
también siempre tuve el apoyo de el
padre charlie el si cada vez que íbamos
a la iglesia lo había orar por mí para
que yo me pudiera curar para que yo
estuviera bien siempre lo hizo y para mí
siempre ha sido un buen amigo y lo será
a lo que quiero llegar es siempre
tenemos la oportunidad de ayudar el
punto es la tomamos o la dejamos por eso
por eso y pues a mí ayudar me hizo ver
el lado bueno y el lado malo como por
ejemplo con el yin y el yang
por eso yo lo que yo digo es
la empatía es un gran apoyo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]